ellen degeneres is under fire again
after more
co-workers from her show have stepped
forward with accusations of a toxic work
environment
i think that i was a nice person to
begin with and i hope i've gotten nicer
i don't think you achieve anything by
bullying people
i think we help a lot of people i love
making people happy and making people
feel good but it is who i am
you know innately is ellen's culture of
kindness
just for cameras we bought you a house
that's the claim of some staffers in
this new buzzfeed article which contains
interviews with one current and 10
former employees of the ellen degeneres
show
all of whom asked to remain anonymous
according to the article some said
they were fired after taking medical
leave or bereavement days
another said she walked off the job
because she was
fed up with comments about her race and
others according to buzzfeed said they
were instructed by managers quote to not
speak to degeneres
if they saw her around the office the
show's executive producers responded in
a statement to et today quote
the day-to-day responsibility of the
ellen show is completely on us
we have strived to create an open safe
and inclusive work environment
we are truly heartbroken to learn that
even one person
in our production family has had a
negative experience
we are committed to do better if you're
on daytime television every single day i
think it's really
important to feel like there's someone
that that
makes you feel like a pal like a friend
back in 2011 ellen seemed to poke fun at
her image in this funny face-off with
kimmel
your skin is so smooth and soft it looks
like it would be like a newborn dolphin
or something
[Applause]
okay somebody give me some water
oh oh oh please get miss degeneres some
water immediately
this is for jimmy i just so worried
about you getting dehydrated i worry
about you so much sometimes
and when ellen got her own tv show in
the early 90s she joked to us
about being too nice i'm learning i'm
going to a
school right now like how about this hey
you'll do what i say or else
that's just new i mean i'm just getting
used to it i'm you know i'm just
starting
meanwhile ellen has solid support from
this couple her friend and dj
twitch and his wife allison a familiar
face on the show
you know in recent months her character
has been called into question what do
you say to those critics
uh i don't say no i don't say nothing to
them really because i don't know who any
of them are i don't
know if she knows who any of them are
she's up in a high place and
people love to take cracks when they got
time i mean we'll always try to tear
people that are on top down
[Music]
you